[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous allons passer sept
éditions dc espace autochtone en direct
à parler des pensionnats aujourd'hui
savez qui s'est passé beaucoup de choses
entre autres un historien denis vaugeois
qui a beaucoup parlé des pensionnats
aujourd'hui il était invité à l'émission
plus on est de fous plus on parle et il
a dit que les pensionnats n'était pas
une réalité québécoise alors ça nous a
vraiment interpellé ça va nous permettre
d'en parler à travers des livres entre
autres et puis une exposition qui est
présenté à montréal de kent monkman lui
même fait référence au pensionnat
autochtone alors vous voyez beaucoup
d'actualité autour de ce sujet là nous
allons en parler avec deux invités et
notre chroniqueuse et liquid bonjour
éligible un jour avec vous est riche on
va parler de pensionnat autochtone mais
on va s'intéresser en fait au regard que
les enfants portent sur les pensions oui
et comment s'adresser ce sujet là pour
les enfants voilà donc de l'écriture de
la littérature pour enfants sur le thème
des pensionnats et puis cette semaine il
ya un livre qui est sorti le 13 février
bill hideki de l'auteur sonia perron
nous allons la joindre à radio canada
saguenay bonjour sonia bonjour alors
sonia c'est vous qui avez écrit cet
ouvrage vous êtes réalisatrice à radio
canada saguenay
mais depuis très longtemps vous vous
intéressez aux autochtones et surtout au
sujet des pensionnats mais je pense que
c'est parfois dans la vie on a des
chemins comprend pompe on sait pas où
est ce que ça va nous mener oui là
j'étais jeune femme j'étais journaliste
à télé québec cmq première expérience
quasiment de reportages nationaux et j y
avait une émission qui a été mise sur
pieds je pense qu'elle s'appelait nation
et on est en 95 peut-être 94 et pour les
premières fois je suis allé faire des
reportages donc c'était parfait parce
que on avait tellement de choses à
apprendre alors j'étais avec un
réalisateur alain corneau et puis on est
allés boire on est allé faire des
reportages j'ai rencontré bibiane j'ai
procédé s'en souvient mais moi je m'en
souviens tu ouvrais la porte on va tout
de suite la présenter
bibiane courtois elle est là en skype
avec nous aujourd'hui vous êtes à
roberval bonjour bibiane bonjour ou et
alors me laissa donc bibiane vous vous
vous connaissez donc depuis très
longtemps est finalement bibiane vous
avez été une bonne source d'information
pour sonia si je comprends bien
williams a consulté quelques reprises
sur différents sujets lors de sa
rédaction et j'ai tenté du possible la
supporter la banque
je trouve ça extrêmement intéressant
parce qu'elles comprennent pas oui
allait dès le début je peux vous dire
parce que je laisse des messages est ce
que je peux vous parler attelage avait
des questions souvent des fois qu'ils
pouvaient être intime même sur votre vie
qui se rappelle but bien joué au début
j'étais prêt à y aller doucement mais
c'est sur votre réalité de femmes quand
vous aviez 18 20 ans roberval et tout ça
alors c'était très très inspiré lors
c'est cette femme je dois le dire
personnellement m'a inspiré beaucoup
sont partis de grande dame que l'on est
moins alors c'est une grande dame que
j'ai eu le privilège de rencontrer une
équipe on vend aussi des portes et je
les ai vus dans le feu de l'action et je
sais que sa maman ou c'était une femme
très impliquée dans sa communauté
c'est des femmes fortes c'est des femmes
qui ont une communauté c'était pas
facile je prends les propos de viviane
bien les familles de la droite est ce
vous je crois mais parler de la cedeao
kleberson important pour moi c'est une
femme importante
oui quand vous parlez de la communauté
si la communauté de mashteuiatsh ou lac
saint jean mes voisins c'est nos voisins
oui bien sûr bien drôle ramasse hougaard
chekwa 7km cetc
c'est patrice à peu près oui mais mais
en fait sonia l'expiration du romain ne
vous est pas venu de bibiane elle vous
est venue de quelqu'un d'autre
ouais en fait sans rentrer dans les
détails parce que je respecte la vie
privée de cette berline vient suffit
qu'un homme me donne une lettre j'étais
en reportage depuis plusieurs semaines
j'étais allé passer des semaines une
semaine complète en repérage
il était ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui je
sais pas comment une femme un fixeur
c'est lui qui m'a menée sur la
communauté
rencontrer les gens me trouver de
l'hébergement parce qu'elle est produite
à lui tout ça mais j'ai passé eu au
moins une semaine avec lui retournez en
reportage revenus pour d'autres mieux
pour la radio et cela cette fois là il
me donnait une lettre et je me rappelle
je prenais la ouate il y avait de la
neige dit je veux pas que cela les sites
utilisent chez toi donc j'étais mal
comment je les lui à deux kilomètres
plus loin
je me suis assise et pisi terre en gros
il disait je m'appelais pas et je suis
maintenant un autre
oui j'ai passé jusqu'à 17 ans ma vie au
pensionnat et j ai cette drôle parce
qu'à l'intérieur des belges où cela
comme un poème un peu il disait qu'il y
avait appris de belles choses sous
passionnant la française
c'est un homme qui écrivait très très
bien et puis après ça mais il ya raconté
qui est abusée beaucoup beaucoup pendant
plusieurs années
il me souvient faut que tu racontes ça
je raconte pas son histoire j'agonise
cette histoire où ils travers mon
imaginaire mais tout seul je ne gère
toujours en parler parce que c'est comme
1,94 je connaissais pas ça qu'est ce que
vous voulez comme d'ailleurs percée oui
il peut gérer connais cette famille wii
party de famille cette annonce je vous
savez pas ils partent avec les enfants
foyer ou de brice est alors donc ça m'a
habité beaucoup parlent moins aussi
parce que ce sont des enfants moi je
suis une maman une grand-maman tous les
enfants qu'on nous confie on doit en
prendre soin et ça pas du tout été le
cas pour la plupart de ces jeunes
enfants particulièrement dans les années
que je raconte
oui le pire là dedans entre les années
20 et les années 40 50
c'était vraiment épouvantable le taux de
mortalité était stabilisé un peu partout
mais c'est particulièrement utile à
votre histoire vous la situer dans nord
de l'ontario pourquoi parce qu'il y en a
eu des pensionnats au québec
je voulais pas trop me piéger et
il y en eut un seulement à cette époque
là il y avait des foyers un petit peu
qu'on ne suit plus tard il y avait six
pensionnat au québec ces fassis oui mais
en ontario il y en avait beaucoup
oui bien sûr oui oui j'avais aussi une
histoire d'un enfant qui métisse et dont
le père l'amène à son école donc le
faire accepter par parce qu'il y avait
des métis mais c'est toujours un peu
compliqué zadeh passe-passe pour que ça
fonctionne tout pour que les enfants
soient acceptés alors c'était plus
simple et je voulais pas aussi nommé ni
communauté ni de nom de ville j'ai juste
mis en ontario québec pour pommes ont
montré des enfants 1945 visité en
soixante dix que ça s'est passé mon
histoire donc il fallait que je serais
aussi les comment je dirais je sais pas
si vous savez on n'avait pas beaucoup de
références à l'époque en soixante dix on
savait pas trop ce qui se passe il y
avait encore des pensionnés au québec
ça a été des années difficiles plus au
québec je dirais même que dans les
provinces où déjà les passionnés avaient
commencé à fermer mais bien peut-être me
corriger ça j'aurais honte et baic a
envoyé une photo là c'étaient des
enfants dans un pensionnat je pense que
ça ressemblait beaucoup à ça c'était pas
vous l'avez vu la photo bibiane bouillon
début oui mais vous bien c'est ça ça
vous vous n'avez vous n'avez pas
fréquenté les pensionnats bibiane non
non j'ai pas vous écartez les
pensionnats cependant fondre
pensionnaire de ma communauté a ouvert
en 1960
oui je me souviens encore à
l'adolescence à l'époque que je me
souviens de l'arrivée des enfants au
pensionnat nous on savait pas trop ce
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des
murs mais on voyait débarquer les
enfants de l'autobus d'ailleurs oui
d'ailleurs qui arrive à des communautés
et on les éloigner de leurs communautés
un fait de tous petits enfants cinq en
six ans c'est pleurais je me souviens de
ces images la tête et j'ai laissons
aussi d'entendre des enfants pleurent
rive mais c'est les ce sont les
souvenirs puis ensuite vint cela qu'ils
étaient plus vieux on allait aller
l'ensemble à roberval et qu'on sera
encore là les autobus mais on avait de
la difficulté même à communiquer parce
que souvent parlé pas la même langue
alors ce mois ci les soutenir que et de
cette époque là oui mais mais mais
bibiane vous dites que vous n'avez pas
présente
fréquenter le pensionnat mais est-ce que
vous avez de la famille des amis autour
qui sont allés dans des pensionnats
ailleurs loin de pointe bleue j'ai connu
des gens qui sont allés à l'extérieur
effectivement dans le nord du québec qui
ont été pensionnaire j'ai deux frères
qui sont pas les pensionnaires dans le
pensionnat de ma communauté mais de
façon temporaire seulement mais j'aimais
sinon les enfants les enfants et qui
envoyait dans le nord de l'ontario aussi
polyvalent du québec à d'accord ok
parfait oui ok il ne changerait pas même
temps ils ont laissé loyer de la maison
moi je pense qu'on appelait à l'époque
aujourd'hui je pense à un cheese
exactement exactement c'est le seul
pensionnat qu'ils étaient ouverts à
cette époque là au québec
oui en 1936 si je me trompe pas mais les
autorités sont arrivées après les années
ok il a commis chez nous qui ont truc en
plus passionnelle d'accord est donc le
dernier pensionnat où québec a fermé
c'était celui donc de pointe bleue de
m'acheter hoyas et il a fermé en 1991
avec oui alors sonia donc vous êtes
inspirés des témoignages de celui de
bibiane et d'une autre personne pourra
presse à construire ce livre là en fait
ça plus commencer par la recherche un
peu par curiosité je suis quelqu'un de
très très curieux alors j'ai commencé à
écouter lire des documents faire venir
la commission royale d'enquêté sur les
peuples autochtones
je vous rappelle monsieur téléphonistes
pourquoi vous voulez ça ça m'intéresse
et puis j'ai pris toute la section des
passionnants puis je sais pas c'est
comme si un petit peu obsessive quand je
suis content quand je commence je
comprends je veux savoir comment ça
fonctionne puis après ça si les motifs
qui embarque j'étais une réalisatrice
télé et radio je racontais j'avais
merveilleux médium pour aller rencontrer
bibiane rencontrer d'autres personnes
faire des reportages avec toutes sortes
de choses que j'ai faites dans ce
merveilleux métier et depuis quelques
années mon corps est plus compliqué
alors je pense que c'est instinctivement
que j'ai créé autrement j'ai créé avec
des mots je pense que de suite logique
un peu le documentaire beaucoup que
jamais alors si c'est ça c'est un
mélange un mélange de tout plusieurs
années on écrit quatre ans parce que oui
même si j'ai repris après souverain
entend corriger pour le renvoyer à
nouveau aux éditeurs c'est un long
parcours mais oui c'était points au
début un plan j'avais pas pantoute
pendant toute l'idée d'écrire un roman
j'ai commencé il ya peu près six ans
cette histoire là sur la galerie en été
mais vous avez choisi de le traiter sous
forme de roman est-ce que c'était la
meilleure chose à faire pour raconter
cette histoire parce qu'elle est
multiple cette histoire ils sont des
milliers à travers le canada à l'avoir
vécu dans plus de 150 pensionnat je
pense que le choix que j'ai fait de ne
pas nommer deux communautés
oui de faire comme d'une petite histoire
la grande histoire
je vous comprenez ce m à travers ses
petits enfants lors et ce personnage là
le prête et saas et c'est sur un reflet
un peu de cette histoire là que s'est
passé partout au pays et gérant choisi
1945 parce que c'étaient des amis dur
pour les gens québec ou si on est dans
temps de la guerre est mais je les
chiffres depuis son agrément
on avait moins cher pour le pensionnat
autochtone que pour le pensionnaire même
s'il a manqué aussi dans les pensionnats
du sud mais on avait moins imaginez-vous
il était dans le fin fond de l'ontario
où l'abbé du son dans les endroits
difficiles pour la nourriture une eau et
la main mais des indes
il y avait en même temps de la
créativité on avait des jardins des
animaux des arbres c'est un univers
alors quand je suis rentré dans sa
j'avais le goût de raconter plus cette
période là puis un peu dans le fond ma
jeunesse 1970 un petit peu mais aussi le
bien aussi souviens je te tutoie
il m'a raconté qu'ils avaient un
restaurant un coût est à roberval
samedi ce qu'ils veulent quand carte
polynésiens ça s'invente pas et ça c'est
images leur reste et je répète ma vie
n'avait jusqu'à mes nerfs et c'est ça
hein quand un look et en plus ça oui oui
69 70 ans tu m'avais dit alors tous au
fait que ça fait comme willow roman
s'est imposée parce que ben comme je
vous dis je n'avais pas vraiment
tribunes j'étais habitué de de réaliser
des documentaires tous à l'horizon des
choses faire des entrevues tout là
j'avais pas cet espace là alors je suis
entré là dedans puis j'avais le goût
aussi que les gens connaissent cette
histoire là alors c'est à ce moment là
raconte également qu on prenne pas trop
oui l'histoire raconte pas ce qu'on peut
pas important
l'histoire c'est bill hideki dont bill
idée qui sait comme billy the kid parce
que sa maman est allée au cinéma avait
vu le film billy the kid et elle a
décidé de donner ce nom là est son
enfant trouve ça très original et donc l
est il est placé en pensionnat etc les
sévices qu'il va subir ces les sévices
que tous ses petits amis autour de lui
vont subir et c'est ensuite après la
révélation de ce lourd secret parce que
ça a été un très lourd secret pour pour
de nombreux enfants y en a peut-être qui
le vivent encore ce secret là certains
évidemment se sont dévoilés ça a permis
d'amener l'arrestation de prêtres de
purée qui a ouvert non tout ça est
justement dans votre livre rien étals et
n'est inventé tout ce que vous racontez
est arrivé un peu partout au canada mais
autres c'est ça oui comme vous dites par
tout cas n'avait pas je voulais pas
justement me piéger avec un itinéraire
précis moins nombreuse dario ça c'est un
peu ça pouvait faire pour pour un
immense yona là ils ont toujours été que
que vont créer pour être dans un endroit
isolé ellip6 attikameks allait dans la
communauté du bien
mas triage fait que c'était vraiment
volontaire ce geste lent mais bien mais
je lis des témoignages ils disaient que
je ne parle pas votre langue c'est très
fort
ne parlez pas là mais là c'est violent
on est dans les années 40 c'était
vraiment mais spéciaux ouais je ne parle
pas votre langue fait pour les enfants
c'est énorme
il revenait à l'été moi je sais charles
coucou un grand leader me l'a raconté
dans c dans le train revenir après dix
mois pas être capable par les hommes il
faut alors là il ya un clash qui se
passait entre les parents les parents
voulaient gâter les enfants les enfants
savaient pas trop comment s'y prend on
est un peu gêné je résume mais c'est ce
que j'ai lu je vais lui des centaines de
fois oui et c'est ce que vous racontez
aussi dans le livre et c'est très très
bien très très bien écrit très bien
expliqué bibiane des ans et skate
vous en avez connu des gens qui vous ont
raconté ce qui leur était arrivé dans
les pensionnats
j'ai rencontré quelques femmes qui m'ont
qui m'ont raconté qu est ce que vous
avez vécu dans les pensionnats ces
femmes là était très souffrante à
l'époque où je les ai rencontrés
ça a été des moments je dirais très
difficile à passer et accompagner c'est
pas moi aussi maintenant je me souviens
encore j'ai encore dans ma tête des
rencontres que j'ai faites avec
certaines de ces fables en est à sept
fois plus on comprenait pas trop qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est pourquoi cette
personne avait un problème pourquoi il y
avait un problème au niveau de la
famille la présentation était infirmière
ou si vous étiez un fermier à y
travailler avec le mans vous la prise en
charge de ces enfants même il y avait
comme une déconnexion qui se passe est
qu'on comprenait pas puis au finissait
par savoir bout d'un certain temps qu'il
y avait eu des abus par exemple ouais
c'est pas évident on en a rencontré
quelques-unes mais je pense que quand on
a regardé les rapports de la commission
denquête on a pu voir qu'il y avait eu
un énorme match france à travers tout le
pays
gilles et c'est là que vous avez
découvert l'ampleur de cette tragédie
finalement effectivement parce que quand
on était prêts on ne voyait pas un gars
ils m'y attendais collé sur la bourre
pour m'avoir l'horizon un oui
ensuite quand ça s'ouvre qui sait
comment ça commence à voir des
dénonciations et et commence à avoir des
situations de crise
maintenant on est obligé e puis on voit
que ce qui se passe le rayonnement et
quels sont les impacts surtout qu'ils
sont encore aujourd'hui
oui justement j'avais vous posez la
question oui les impacts vous les voyez
toujours de génération en génération c
impact cela se répercute 1 fectivement
de génération en génération quand on
enlève à des parents des enfants ont
leur arrive aussi le devenir parents et
comment comment ai je donne notre
parentalité séparant l'eau quand ils
trouvent leurs enfants ils sont
proprement se comporter avec leurs
enfants comment comment élever les
enfants plus haut ça se répercute de
génération en génération quand on
regarde les enfants de ces familles la
maison papillon pas eu de modèle de ma
main il y aura eu de bons mais quand ce
sont eux mêmes des enfants à charge
oui alors je reviens à cette entrevue
qui a été donnée à l'émission plus on
est de fous plus on lit à radio canada
cette semaine par l'historien denis
vaugeois qui disait donc les pensionnats
c'est pas une réalité autochtone est ce
que ça vous choque bibiane d'entendre ça
quand on dit c'est pas une réalité
québécoise parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont dans le déni de la réalité
québécoise la réalité québécoise est là
et ça me choque
oui effectivement j'ai lu sawyer que je
me suis dit que c'est ça moi je pensais
que cette personne là qu'il était un
l'historien biais documenté je me rends
compte que
non c'est chacun de gagner une réalité
de cette ampleur là je sais pas je pense
que je pense que il ya eu beaucoup de
commentaires à ce sujet lauriers je
pense que je m'associe pas mal de
commentaires qui se sont présentés dans
l'immédiat oui je pense qu'ils ont
encore le comble anticipe à cette
douleur là c'est pas une histoire du
nombre de pensionnaires du nombre
d'enfants c'est une réalité qu'il ya des
fois ça n'était pas exactement dans tout
les mêmes communautés de la même façon
il ya eu des petits mots les petites
écoles mais en général 6 6 qui s'est
passé 186 je pense au pays
186 pensionnat oui s'il traverse
champions on revient toujours 150 et
plus cela le chili peppers saison oui
c'est tout ça il ya des enfants
bah oui et si à 186 pensionnat il ya des
milliers d'enfants qui sont placés par
les pensionnats parce que ça a duré
longtemps là ça commençait quoi 1880 et
quelques pour aller jusqu'en 1996 le
dernier oui le gros pic si on peut dire
était plus dans les années 30 40
oui un des pensionnats pensionnat au
québec celui là d'ailleurs ou et qu'on
voit actuellement à l'écran la a lieu
que les récents désordres
je vous dis quand on pense qu'ils
avaient les passionnants 1900 quelques
imaginez-vous l'état aussi dans tout ça
ça devait d'abord complètement fou à
faire et et pour ces enfants là le
voyage était complètement dément
aujourd'hui prendre la route c'est déjà
demain
quand on est tout petit bureau doit
aller si loin voici ces produits-là en
ontario oui ouais voilà alors ce qu'il
faut faire maintenant évidemment c'est
éduquer les gens éduqués à ne pas
oublier non plus hein c'est important de
comprendre que ça existe et on ne peut
pas se permettre de l'oublier et elie je
me tourne vers hellich d'ailleurs si
vous avez envie de poser des questions
ne vous gênez pas hellich on va parler
il ya cet ouvrage donc de sonia ben
l'idée qui mais il ya aussi un ouvrage
qui est paru il ya dix ans oui mais qui
va être réédité
alors ça s'appelle faty l'egs donc il
est sorti en 2010 par deux deux femmes
en fait c'est la mère et la fille qui
ont travaillé sur cet ouvrage la
fatidique un an un ouvrage qui est
destiné aux enfants
oui alors c'est la femme mais regrette
pour kingston sont nos minorités ou le
maine et puis elle et inuites du
territoire de nord-ouest oui et puis
elle écrit ce livre avec sa belle fille
à sa belle oui c'est avec sa belle-fille
oui et puis c'est très intéressant que
l'évolution de ce projet parce que en
famille
madame pour qui accentue n'a commencé au
fait des années de parler de plus en
plus de son expérience dans un
pensionnat autochtone aux territoires du
nord-ouest et sa belle-fille voulu
trouver des livres ou les livres
d'histoire pour ses enfants pour qu'ils
comprennent mieux l'expérience de leur
camp mais oui mais elle rien trouvé elle
dit qu'à l'époque yves bot beaucoup sur
les pensionnats autochtones encore moins
qui vise les enfants way et ceux qui
étaient existe et ça met plus l'accent
sur la victimisation des élèves au lieu
de la résilience ou les petites
résistances oui alors ils ont décidé à 2
de créer un livre
d'accord alors le livre en anglais lui
s'appelle faty l'egs en français ça
s'appelle là je vais le montrer parce
que j'ai la feuille ça s'appelle les bas
du pensionnat alors les basses et les
chaussettes la célèbre ac oui les bad du
pensionnat pourquoi parce que la petite
fille elle était un peu résistante
voyais là on le voit bien mais là encore
la thèse d'un rouleur jouets ils sont
mal et ça vient ça devienne impossible
parce que madame peau qui accentue qu'on
l'était au pensionnat youn soeur qui l'a
forcé de protéger bowler les bas rouges
oui les autres fils ont papoté ça pour
l'humilier et puis pour que vienne un
peu ainsi mais on voit à travers les
livres
madame pochettino trouver une façon de
se débarrasser de ça alors on voit c'est
une symbol dans les livres mais à la fin
de livre en voit comment la petite fille
sort de cette histoire d'accord et ça
c'est un livre qui existe depuis dix ans
et qui est extrêmement populaire dans la
littérature pour enfants au canada
oui et pas juste pour les livres sur les
pensionnats cape town pour les livres
pour enfants et même après 10 ans se
livrent cette série maintenant sa figure
toujours sur les peines dans les
bibliothèques ou les top ten des livres
pour les enfants canadiens alors c'est
c'est comme c'était très populaire quand
c'est sorti et ça continue même après 10
ans et c'est pour ça qu'il va être
réédité
oui alors le dixième anniversaire de la
première édition c'est en 2020 oui ils
sont en train de préparer une édition
spéciale pour marquer l'occasion mais
aussi il faut dire que le premier half
at-il aigles les bords du pensionnat ça
parle de l'expérience que madame poker
fanta ou dans le pensionnat
mais ils ont fait une suite aussi qui
s'appelle étrangères chez moi et quand
on vient de parler ça parle de caisse
qui est arrivé après deux ans oui elle
était de retour dans sa communauté qui
elle parlait plus la langue sa mère
parle pas anglais
n'est pas capable de parler avec sa mère
que et aussi le fait qu'avant ça doit
être préférée c'était la nourriture
traditionnelle inuite bien sûr mais à
moins 2 ans dans le pensionnat
autochtone l'avait oublié quand elle a
mangé sa était plus capable de le
tolérer
et c'était quelque chose qui nous tracte
émotionnel oui assez c'est l'histoire de
billy des qui aussi quand il retourne
dans sa communauté retourner voir sa
mère après quelques années et puis il
est devenu un étrange
pourtant avec sa petite valise avec son
crucifix toutes ces petites choses qui
bougent elle aime beaucoup mobilisé
comme il existe pour moi dans mon coeur
viviane rit je pense qu'il est vraiment
présente mon gars et c'est ça quand il
retourne puis si c'est sa mère le col
l'embrassait attention ta mère en plus
comme militer d'une mère seule methi's
l'enfant est un métier la mer avec vont
donc alors il y avait averti l'enfance
et fait attention ces péchés qu'elle te
touche se donne alors pour l'enfance et
c'est moi cette image les efforts tous
les soirs et se cachent pour pâques à 8
au jeu puis la nuit une quelquefois is
life qui le regarde il a tous un peu
c'est beaucoup ça quand on t'envoie pipi
ces enfants là où il voulait être
heureux aussi c'est si on parle beaucoup
c'est triste mais il y avait quand même
dans les enfants et toujours ce boulot
de vie je pense que je me trouvais il
faut malgré le drame et tous ces belles
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils ont passé
par le mans samedi
donc nous sommes sereins but mais on
peut grandir
c'est comme si on ne peut pas non plus
tout bloquer ce alors pour moi aussi ça
l'espoir leglise oh c'est pas juste du
noir il ya aussi de l'espoir
je pense que oui mais oui la ville
ben oui bien sûr oui il ya une notion
d'espoir en effet et c'est ce que montre
aussi les livres pour enfants
mais j'imagine qu'il ya eu des défis
pour écrire ses livres là surtout il ya
dix ans + wii ne parlait pas beaucoup
dès maintenant et puis aussi pour les
deux écrivaines et il avoue c'était très
difficile de voir comment comment
calibrer le temps d'un livre de tels
sujets pour les enfants il entrave et
deux ans avec un rédacteur juste pour
trouver le bon façon de ranger et puis
finalement comme c'est évident le les
illustrations ou l'explication graphique
de la violence ça ne va pas pour les
petits enfants mais c'était pas
nécessaire pour vraiment parler de
l'impact que ça c'est un enfant parce
que juste comme dans le livre étrangères
chez moi tous les enfants peut
s'identifier avec l'expérience de madame
poker fenton 2 après deux ans après des
pertes de revenir et être plus capable
de parler avec une grande masse comme un
peu la langue alors est dit avec ça on
peut communiquer le fait de les
pensionnats autochtones mais sans les
images qui peut traumatiser les césar
exact donc il ya eu les bas du
pensionnat la traduction en français il
ya eu étrangères chez moi et là il ya
une autre version pour des plus petits
encore des plus petits enfants
exactement soit après le succès de ses
deux livres là ils ont décidé de faire
les versions pour les enfants de 6 à 9
ans c'est plus les livres d'image ce
qu'ils ont réécrit le livre encore pour
que ce soit approprié pour ces enfants
là
et puis en français ça s'appelle quand
j'avais 8 ans ça vient de sortir
alors ça c'est autre chose et puis on a
là on est à l'image de ce livre là et
puis a sauvé le sait ça maintenant c'est
paul et les gens au québec où si on leur
livre qui qui montrent le mr oui ça
c'est publié chez scholastic ce qui veut
dire qu'en fait que ce soit la version
anglaise la version française c'est
disponible partout à travers le canada
trouve au canada et on le voit sa
remporté énormément de succès est ce que
les livres et ils se rendent jusque dans
les écoles est ce que les enfants accès
dans les économies et quand j'ai parlé
avec la belle fille de madame poké akfen
un acteur très très beaucoup d'impact
mais les deux il parle des données de
secours dans les écoles partout au
canada à peu près 100 parrainer qui met
le belle fille de madame pompiers qui
fonctionne a dit que justin et de
semaine sa fille qui a 15 ans la plaie
pour dit qu'elle est aux besoins des
d'avec ses devoirs oui et quand elle est
montée dans la chambre pour les dés
étaient en train d'étudier ferry l'ex la
version anglaise de ce livre là et qui
sont maintenant c'est dans les écoles
dans certaines écoles
il regarde ça et puis elle dit pour moi
après dix ans de travail que je fais que
ma belle-mère
on voit que ça apporte quelque chose lui
et maintenant je suis aussi pour mes
enfants de voir que on étudie l'histoire
de leur grand-mère dans les écoles ça
donne comme une validation à
l'expérience de ceux pour les gens
équipés que ça aucun absolument sonia
est ce que votre livre éventuellement
pourraient se retrouver justement dans
les classes parce que c'est une lecture
accessible à tous
uniquement sur des bouts difficile un
peu peut-être pour les petits à
peut-être pas pour les partis non mais
au niveau secondaire les arcs oui mais
en même temps il faut avoir les mots et
maux sont les mots car le geste et fait
le geste effet il existe alors c'est un
beau d'ailleurs qu'il 36 l écrire oui
vous devez savoir de quoi je parle et
c'est très très difficile à écrire c'est
épouvantable voyez j'en parle j'ai les
yeux dans les eaux puis c'est pour avoir
fait aussi beaucoup d'autres lectures
comme pour avoir écouté les tirs des
histoires d'horreur avec des jeunes
enfants mangent à couches minces
c'est ça alors mais j'aimerais que ben
quand je vous parlais mon petit devoir
de mémoire mon monde pense que c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait beaucoup si oui
aussi je dois besoin de raconter cette
histoire de faire une histoire aussi
j'aime raconter des histoires mais
j'avais le goût là que le monde
comprendra un car je le disais le plus
je me faisais obstiné le célèbre genre
comme un seul homme
alors ça ça chabal ça va régler le
dossier pour saper obstiné mais il faut
imaginer mon image du village sans
enfant j'étais allé tourner à l'époque
dans une petite communauté et pour le
tournage on est allé dans la cour
d'école jeudi on va aller voir les
enfants allaient tourner pendant qu'ils
jouent d'or on va laisser la caméra fixe
oui et quand il ya plus d'enfants bon on
va mélanger l'image et il y aura plus
rien il rassure tout le silence et c'est
comme dans les films est arrivé un chien
blanc au il s'est promené partout dans
la cour du voir à quelles règles sont à
terre puis est reparti cette usine c'est
comme ça c'était comme ça c'est vrai oui
puis oubliant tout à l'heure que le 10
et le rôle de parent ça s'apprend pas
comme ça c'est difficile de devenir
parent c'est à présent soit musulman par
année ça donne pas de chance comme on
dit et s'ils sont inaccessibles ni par
téléphone ni par courrier n'est pas
retournée parier c'est souvent il y
parvient mais qui partait comme le mien
est parti trois ans c'est ça dépendait
des fois aussi des chemins des sortes de
facteurs wild et port la responsabilité
d'un enfant
oui mais quand je dis comme l'histoire
si belle que que la chroniqueuse raconte
je me rappelle plus riches et et c'est
vraiment l'histoire de tous ses
petits-enfants l'heure du village v22
c'est ça c'est important un seul enfant
c'est un bis bien vous avez été
directrice du musée de m'acheter watts
est ce que est ce que au musée on parle
des pensionnats est-ce qu'on est ce
qu'il ya une pièce une salle qui raconte
l'histoire des pensionnats à l'époque où
j'étais là il y en avait pas on en
parlait entre nous entre les
travailleurs et avec les gens de la
communauté
il n'y avait pas nécessairement à
l'époque les expositions concernant les
passionnants je pense qu'il ya eu
dernièrement l'année dernière où il ya
deux ans il ya eu une exposition
itinérante qui circulait qui est venu
pendant quelques temps d'acheter ryad
b par contre j'ai vu de très belles
expositions personnelles et pensionnés
en colombie-britannique et j'aurais bien
aimé que ces expositions ne plus venir
chez nous chose qui pour capter encore
mais peut-être un jour ça se fera parce
qu'il ya eu là je pense que dans
plusieurs provinces à des expositions
qui ont été montés sur ces sujets là oui
oui les jeunes que j'ai consulté
beaucoup parce que si les gens veulent
aller voir c'est que sont les enfants
devenus c'est très beau comme titre et
c'est un site qui était très bien en
français et ça raconte l'histoire des
pensionnats ya des photos
exceptionnelles il ya des témoignages et
de l'audio de la vidéo c'est super bien
fait c'est sûr que c'est moins québécois
parce qu'il est plus produit dans
l'ouest ou laisser la main distribution
début on raconte canadienne aussi mais
c'est sûr que bon les scellés que sont
les enfants devenus tapées sur le net et
vous allez passez un moment émotif et
vous allez apprendre beaucoup moi
c'était un des outils pour com1 ça
comprend on va demander je refuse la rue
des zones estre de l'ajouter sur notre
sur la page web que sont les enfants
devenus vous l'avez vu bibiane ce site
là vous le connaissez pas c'est plein de
sujets les bus parce que c'est dans les
belles mais c'est parce qu'elle est
disponible ce qui est agréable c'est que
les disponibles virtuellement français
fait que si si les gens veulent aller
voir ça donne un bon regard voilà puis
entre temps donc on va leur proposer de
lire votre ouvrage donc
l'idée qui de sonia paieront alors le
dernier mot je vais le donner à bibiane
vous en avez pensé quoi du livre bibiane
j'avais perdu mes ya soit juste que je
reste avec un immense sentiment de
respect tout au long du jeu j'en ai vu
que ça que je respect dans notre langue
on dit je t'appelle tu as moins il peut
pas être correspond et s'est vraiment
senti toulon connaissant l'histoire
qu'au dessin la situation j'ai juste été
capable de saisir chaque mot la valeur
de chaque mot et doit-on vraiment là
dedans pips c'est ce qui m'a marqué le
plus bas soit parce que c'est ça a été
peut-être une ligne sans le savoir tout
du long
à l'approché de visu et de la vérité oui
les ailes mais petit bonhomme aussi
c'est publié chez fides donc il est déjà
disponible en librairie vraiment c'est
une très belle découverte
à lire billy d'equipe merci à toutes les
deux merci bibiane courtois en direct de
roberval merci sonia perron en direct de
saguenay merci hellich queen en direct
de montréal la semaine prochaine et les
jeux vous abandonne moi je serai à
saguenay la semaine prochaine on va
faire notre facebook live à partir de
saguenay parce que il ya un colloque de
la socam
donc on va parler des radios
communautaires
inoue attikameks parce qu on fête
l'anniversaire le 30e anniversaire de la
socam donc on va profiter de cette
occasion pour faire notre facebook live
à partir de saguenay merci à tous merci
à mes invités et à très bientôt
au revoir
[Musique]